like it also is okay it's contrary to at
that point as well when men are overly
controlling with next women I think
that's Trauma from their past
relationships like if they've been
cheated on what's controlling to you
what's controlling to me um a guy trying
to tell me what I can and cannot wear
where I can and kind of man tells me
that really yeah yeah I don't know how
you you are okay so how are you okay you
wouldn't you really want me to go
outside in a mini skirt and this is
because no but not even like my man
tells me when I come on the podcast I
mustn't show my knees because otherwise
I must be careful than what I wear
because when I step out the house I
representing him nah that's love yeah I
think this ain't naive
okay okay let me ask you something here
let me ask you something you don't you
don't wanna wait wait wait wait you
don't you don't you don't want to be
with a guy that you have well you don't
want to be with a guy that you have to
listen to like you don't want to be with
a guy who's judgment you trust
um
[Laughter]
from a guy's point of view that's really
hard for them to work with because like
to that to a guy when a guy hears that
it's like to me who cares like why does
it it's not gonna affect my life that
much what I wear when I go out of the
house and I want to be I want to be with
a guy who's judgment that I trust right
so it's like when a guy hears that he
just hears that you won't cooperate with
him that you're that you're hard to work
with that you that you you're stubborn
he's just throwing his toys out of
camera okay no no no no no no no no no
it's not it's not because again most
most guys want a girl that will submit
to him and Trust his judgment right
would you agree with that yeah so so if
his judgment and he says hey you know
what I don't want there to be problems
could you change your top like your
boobs are out or whatever it is and you
say well but like that's a headache to
him no but it's not about what you're
describing is a conversation and I think
as though if you have a conversation you
say oh you know what you're wearing I
can't I don't like it I'll be like Fez
at least we're having a conversation
about it you're not coming at me but
even but even
he just says it even if he just says hey
change your top of course yeah that's
fine he's not
he's not a dumb but he said it's
controlling to tell me what I can and
cannot wear so if he says change your
top to me I think I think it's sexy when
a guy when a guy has standards
I think it's attractive I agree and so
when a guy hears that you won't do it
that's a small thing to him
that's why I Got Crystal a few yeah so
what Gertrude Gertrude yeah and Gertrude
and Patrick is still together from 1901
yeah and Patrick Patrick been telling
Gertrude Gertrude don't show your knee
Gertrude is not sure this knee but
they're still together and he went for
Gertrude for five years to bang Gertrude
because you know Gertrude is a good girl
I met him with weird for you for three
months okay can I can I can I just say
something what's your name young man
Rick Rick can I just say something
on enough
all the hard times or whatever him tell
him what to do and me doing what he
tells me what to do him telling me that
my head is big and telling me that my
cheeks look like two slaps of lever that
I need to lose some weight him telling
me four weeks late and you know what 32
years I'm counting
there you go because Gertrude listen
just to you know what I'm saying you
know why why does a man tell you a baby
I beg you just cover your boobs of
politically what's wrong with that is it
is it is it out there for a display
Spider-Man to be like what are you
saying baby or is it it's tea isn't it
and in general in general yeah 1901 I'm
pretty sure there was more marriages
than than now and then another thing
happy marriages how do you know how do
you know a lot of abusive marriages
most grandparents are happily married
ask them about their marriage yeah I
wasn't finished I wasn't finished but
most grandparents in general are happily
married the majority of grandparents is
when it gets to our appearance that's
when it kind of starts bringing the
majority of grandparents are happily
married and let me just flip it quickly
here you see as a woman like all right
so you see how much you look Social
Circles now yeah you see like the women
that are like with partners that in
relationships so you see like you are
going out you got that one friend that
she's in a relationship but she's at
every turn up with you every turn up
wearing what she wants she's the last
one on the dark so hey you're not
thinking all right you got a man no but
then but then there's a one there's the
ones that is in a relationship like I
would I would think girls would see it a
little bit better that oh like her man
comes after The Raven and picks her up
and she kind of carry you've noticed
that since she's been in a relationship
she kind of carries herself a little bit
different like she ain't at every turn
up she'll come out like birthdays but
not every turn up it's a little bit
different like and while you're shaking
waiting for an Uber waiting for the man
to pull up in the foreign like her man's
there outside and picking up and going
in with her like there's other little
things going on don't you I don't know
can I ask you freeze what dude I I agree
with you so much okay I agree with you I
don't get what's the question no but
what I said is it's been I'm just it's
going off of what Paul said about um
black when if a man says to you
something like oh change change your
clothes that don't wear that or whatever
yeah so I'm flipping it I'm saying like
because it's a way over
um how a man interacts with his woman
within a relationship here so I'm saying
amongst your Social Circle don't you see
the difference in how like the good
things in what a good man will put into
his woman that marks your friends in
your Social Circle in terms of like not
being at every turn up they've kind of
selectively pull up now and when they
pull up it's a bit different they're not
as out there as it as they was before
they're just a little bit more you know
what I mean and more time afterwards
they're getting picked up that the man's
out there picking them up so don't you
you don't respect it you don't read that
she's like I want yeah no I feel like I
feel like obviously as a single woman or
while you're outside getting grabbed
yeah but I feel like it's all up to the
woman of her she wants to act did you
understand so I feel like as a single
woman if you're outside doing XYZ XYZ
it's going to be different to if you're
in a relationship I'm not in a
relationship right now but where I see
it going with the person I'm talking to
right now would I be out there with Tia
and batia and rare tattoo but if I was
single not to say that I wouldn't have
my ticket but if I'm wearing a pair of
short shorts and I'm going to the club
or the festival or wherever I'm going
I'm not gonna think oh right I'm wearing
this because I like this but if I have a
boyfriend I'm leaving a door he's like
you know what baby like you're batting
them that's for me when we're behind
clothes I don't want your webinar I
would I would take that
would be that nice about it you're gonna
ask you what are you wearing but you're
going out like that but I want to do it
I want to do lots of perspective on Eula
as the single woman looking your
perspective when you're looking on your
friend that's now her relationship
status is cheating now she's got a man
do you not look on that and see how
she's I think yeah like and I think it's
true because I'm not gonna lie a lot of
times I've been in a relationship and
there's there's a red eye friend yeah
because all the time when I was changing
my outfit turning down on my language
cutting down on my drinking not wearing
skirts up to my ass oh even though
you're slim enough to wear it
all my friends had issues with me oh
he's doing it even now he's doing this
he's doing that I know what none of them
got a man and if they did get that man
they'll be doing the same I've had not
more men in that one time the iPad none
of them even got a man they're miserable
especially my sister they're miserable
misery
dogs they got they're just miserable you
know what yeah because they're always
going to turn around and say oh yeah
she's got a man but you know what
because they're miserable leftovers
in relationships they don't they still
will come out or David
um no I don't have any friends that I'm
married now it doesn't really count
unless they've been in the relationship
how does it not but Auntie how long are
you married I'm a leftover woman that
got a ring I was supposed to got a ring
so I'm just the same as you like this I
got more self-respect
it was about how they act when they come
out yeah but when yeah that's what I was
gonna say all my friends act the same
they don't act any different and they
still will go out wearing to eat and
okay
I've got one friend that's been with her
man for seven years yeah submissive
months they've got two kids but he
heard
okay but he's not insecure
now with her with with whatever she
feels like she wants to I'm not saying
though just just my final point is I'm
not saying that if a woman goes out and
like she's wearing something where her
vagina lips are hanging out or it's
really revealing that that's okay like
if I was doing that of course and my mom
was like no then yeah because it looks
scary but I'm saying if I wanted to wear
my cleavage out and stuff like that and
he said no I would think he's trying to
control me okay okay watch it listen
here I'm gonna say something to you live
your life the way you want to live your
life we've been teaching them out leave
your bum cheeks out when you're alone in
15 blood 30 years time but what makes
you think I'll be alone listen because
listening no dumb [ __ ] let some do some
ways
so this is a waste man
that lady's finally yeah as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible